One of the more difficult things
that we have to do as leaders
is let go.
In 2006, I had to take extreme ownership
over a friendly fire incident.
There was only
one person to blame,
and that person was me.
I spent my adult life in the military,
20 years special operations.
I've learned that leadership is the most
important thing on the battlefield.
It's the most important thing in business,
and really, it's the most
important thing in life.
What do you think
makes a good leader?
Cultivating the best
out of people.
Yes, what else?
No matter what your job is,
these skills will help you
in every aspect of your life.
I'm Jocko Willink,
and this is MasterClass.